welcome to hashtag where we use social
media to dig into global story today we
look at how women in Brazil are
combating sexual violence with online
activism via the hashtag you know Marisa
ser esta grata I don't deserve to be
raped it all started at the end of March
when the Brazilian Institute for applied
economic research released the results
of a survey on violence against women
that place the blame mostly on women
fifty nine percent of those polled said
that if women simply change their
behavior there would be less rape and
twenty six percent said that it dressed
provocatively women deserved to be
attacked and raped Brazilian feminists
quickly lit up Twitter in outrage over
the report journalist Nana chaos began
the hashtag a omitted susuri sabaha
and tweeted a provocative photo of
herself others quickly caught on with
sun fired back at the trendy tags
twitter user Sombra said you deserve to
be whipped and stepped on for posting
these semi nude photos on the net
President Dilma Rousseff however tweeted
in solidarity with chaos the government
and the law are on the side of Monica
Ross and women who are endangered or
victims of violence hashtag respects
women women groups like pink Olga have
also used the internet to fight sexual
harassment they run a virtual mapping
campaign called Shahadah few or no more
catcalling where women can anonymously
report where and when they were verbally
and physically assaulted they also
started a shigga a few few hashtag
mayara tweeted
not a compliment no matter what men
think we are not objects on the shelf at
their disposal but the World Cup taking
place right now in Brazil hasn't helped
counter this culture of much easy
instead advertisers have played into
hyper sexualized stereotypes of
Brazilian women earlier this year adidas
pulled what many called sexist World Cup
t-shirts and footlocker's current
Twitter gimmick invites users to hashtag
ask Samba girls questions
amber McGuigan took up the call tweeting
the women are you content with being in
a sexist ad which has nothing to do with
what footlocker sells and that's it for
hashtag tweet us and let us know which
hashtags we should cover next
you